on entend parler espagnol de plus en
plus souvent sur le mont tramelan
faire du ski dans le froid de l'hiver
québécois une expérience exotique pour
les touristes mexicains la chaîne jimmy
wales est ouvertement policière on nous
a conseillé de venir ici parce que les
gens sont gentils et que c'est l'endroit
idéal pour faire du ski
c'est roberto la famille a choisi le
canada pour passer ses vacances
mais pourquoi pas les états unis sont
après tout plus près du mexique par
contre en plus partagé tellement scanner
en partie à cause de donald trump et
parce que je préfère le canada dit il à
la blague pour ces mexicains
le ski est une passion ils sont déjà
allés à whistler et à banff dans les
rocheuses
j'aime l'adrénaline et elle est victime
rihanna et les connaissons ne se
formalise pas de l'hiver je préfère
porter un manteau qu'un maillot de bain
zé roberto fils
si on les croisait rarement il ya
quelques années les touristes mexicains
sont de plus en plus nombreux à dévaler
les pentes du mont tremblant on l'entend
les commerçants n'en parle
on le voit dans les restaurants on le
voit la location les mexicains a shit
pour leurs vacances
qu'est ce qui est à la mode ce qui est
tendance où ils vont aller où la famille
déjà allés donc on commence à voir une
progression de plus en plus de visiteurs
le monde va s'étendre au mexique
le centre de ski fait des efforts pour
s'adapter à cette nouvelle clientèle
les brochures en espagnol sont offertes
tout comme des leçons de ski
las manos une vingtaine de moniteurs
comme antoine peuvent donner des cours
dans la langue maternelle du mexique est
6e pour leur part les veuves les
équipements du foyer arrive pas une
équipe est classée c'est la levée de
l'obligation d'obtenir un visa pour
entrer au canada il ya un peu plus de
deux ans qui a fait exploser le nombre
de touristes en provenance du mexique
pour leur marque dans les laurentides et
aussi à montréal
cent mille mexicains ont visité la
métropole l'année dernière c'est plus du
double qu'en 2015 et ce marché important
de population classes moyennes et
supérieures qui est en forte croissance
que des sous et qui veulent voir
d'autres choses que les studios
la hausse devrait se poursuivre au cours
des prochaines années comme quoi les
mexicains semblent avoir des atomes
crochus avec leurs cousins latins du
nord ici olivier bacharel au canada mont
tremblant